>> FURNICA: Hello. I'm--and welcome to the
YouTube API talk. I am part of the YouTube
API Team I'm a software engineer, I'm Raul
Furnica.
>> NOACK: I'm also a part of the YouTube API
Team, I am Gunther Noack.
>> FURNICA: And we have a third member of
the API team present here, Evan, over there.
We're all based in Zurich and we work--all
work at YouTube/Google from there. So we're
kind of jetlagged right now, we just arrived
yesterday. But hopefully we'll get through
very well. Today, we're going to talk about
the YouTube API in general. And this is going
to be an introduction to the YouTube API and
how to use it. And we're going to have a demo
at the end.
>> NOACK: And also there's--so that, in order
to clarify there's--sometimes there's a misconception
because YouTube actually has two different
types of API. There's the data APIs and the
player APIs. And the player APIs is what you--what
you want to use if you want to actually play
YouTube videos inline into your specific web
apps for instance. And that's not what we're
going to talk about. What we're going to talk
about is the data APIs. That's more about
fetching metadata, about different entities
on YouTube playlist, videos and all that.
Yes.
>> FURNICA: At least we're not going to talk
too much about the player APIs. If you have
any feedback you can give it during the talk
over here. Do I need to leave this slide out
for a while and [INDISTINCT] Kenneth or you're
already done? Okay. Before we go on and we're
going to talk--or we're going to present the
agenda of the talk. I'm actually interested
if anybody have--any of you have used the
YouTube API before or if any of you have created
YouTube applications? Okay. Cool. Okay so,
for the agendum?
>> NOACK: Yes. So, what we're going to show
you today is--we're going to teach you a little
bit about ways that you can use to build applications
that are integrated within the YouTube experience
and that you can use to explore the YouTube
video content. And so, what we're going to
emphasize in this talk is first, the content
discovery, and second, video curation. So,
in this case that's going to be building a
playlist. Yes, that's what we're going to
show. In the end there's--so in the middle,
we're also going to show a little--talk very
shortly about user authentication because
that's also needed for doing--write accesses
and we're all--and in the end we're going
to give a short outlook of what else you can
find in the YouTube API because it's very
large actually. And we're going to show you
a little app Engine demos as well. And there's
going to be questions, yes, I hope.
>> FURNICA: We're also going to be at the
office [INDISTINCT] in one quarter after the
talk. So you can talk to us directly there.
>> NOACK: Yes. So first, I'm going to tell
you a bit about content discovery. So, [INDISTINCT]
here. So maybe you've--if you've got a cellphone
you could--you could scan this link now and
see what you--what you can find.
>> FURNICA: We're trying to keep it very interactive
because otherwise you'd get bored and we'd
get bored, and that's not good.
>> NOACK: So...
>> FURNICA: Anybody got an answer from the
URL above?
>> NOACK: What do you see? I hope no one's
gotten 500 [INDISTINCT] or so. So what you
should have seen, and I hope you have all
seen it, is--[INDISTINCT] my response. And
so, you are now officially already YouTube
API user. We're very proud to have so many
users. All of a sudden. So, what--how you
do request to the YouTube API? It's basically
very simple. It's mostly--most of our request
are just done via http. You construct a URL
like this one. Don't look at it too closely
now, we're going to explain the details later.
And you send a regular http request to this
URL. Usually it's going to be a get and you're
going to get an answer that's in form of an
XML reply. We're adhering to the atom standard
there, that's a bit like our access. And actually
our APIs are also based on atom pop, which
is--which was meant for web blocks originally
but which we extended to also have this--all
these video metadata. And so--and on this
slide you can see two of the most important
tricks that you--those--so these are really
the most important things that you will, hopefully
take from this session. So, first, if you
do any API request, you're going to get a
very ugly response because you try to limit
the bandwidth used for it. Because we--many
of our customers are on mobiles for instance.
So if you add the http for &prettyprint=true
to this--to this URL, you're going to get
prettyprint to the answer, that's a big help
in debugging. And then secondly, there's this
page called gdata.youtube.com which is also
our--the base of the URL for the YouTube API
which looks like this. And what you can do
there is you can experiment with the different
features that the YouTube API offers to you.
So we've got listed most of our features that
we exposed through the API and you can very
simply put together--it's context sensitivity
depending on which service you choose. On
top, you're going to get-- you're going to
get different interface and you can construct
a query interactively, you're going to--going
to see the http headers and URL and you're
going to see the whole response with syntax
highlighting, all of that. It's--that is very
useful for exploring. So if you're-- if you're
ever going to build an app, and I hope, of
course, you will do this, then this is really
the--this is the tool to use in order to figure
out how this--how it works in the big picture.
Okay. So--and--so back to our short example.
So this is the response you are supposed to
get after scanning this QR code.
>> FURNICA: Different titles, though.
>> NOACK: What it is, is--we've got two different
ways of exploring--of discovering content
on YouTube via the API. The first of them
is equivalent to the--to the browse pages
on YouTube. Where you--where you can--where
you can browse through different high scores,
charts of videos and in this case, you've
requested one of these particular charts called
On The Web, which is our--which is actually
this little web block that is--that exists
on the side of YouTube which highlights some
recent trending videos on social networks
on the web. And we put together a list that
is also here on the right. And this contains
the currently trending videos on social networks.
And that you can request through this particular
URL. And this...
>> FURNICA: So it's--just to add to what Gunther
said, it's basically just most shared videos
on other sites for instance, or most used
videos on other sites on this particular.
>> NOACK: And we've got different way--we've
got different charts, of course. We don't
only have these things that are trending on
the web. We also have the things that are
trending on YouTube itself. And we've got
the--we've get high scores of the top most
viewed, most popular, most recent, most discussed
videos and all that. And in order to get them,
you take this URL and you replaced the part
that says On The Web with one of these keywords
here. But there is much more. So we've got
all of that in our documentation page and
you can check it out. Yes, so, and what it
will return you is this--is this XML and in
this case it's a bit trimmed down but it actually
contains a lot of different information about
the videos. So we've got the--not only the
video title of course, we also have streaming
URLs if you want to show it in a player. We've
got descriptions, of course. We've got different
user ratings. We've got--what else do we have?
>> FURNICA: Thumbnails, of course.
>> NOACK: Thumbnails, of course.
>> FURNICA: Basically everything about...
>> NOACK: It's pretty large. It is about--on
a--on a regular screen, it's about this size
for a single video. So we have lots of information.
>> FURNICA: Most of the screen.
>> NOACK: Yes.
>> FURNICA: So in the discovery part, that's
basically the very first step in actually
finding out great content on YouTube, to basically
use the pre-made list of YouTube. And YouTube
has a couple of pre-made list as Gunther mentioned
but if you want to use a more powerful search--a
more powerful tool and you want to actually
build your own list, then search might be
one of the options have to use. And to run
a YouTube API search is basically as easy
as running the URL you see above there with
a query term and a version parameter. The
version parameter basically states which API
version you're going to use right now. You're
going to--you should be using version 2 right
now. It's the latest version of the API. And
there's no sense in using version one anymore.
The query parameter basically might just be
any full text query parameter you might send
on YouTube. And for instance, right now, we're
just searching for football videos. And while
I'm starting very simple I'm going to walk
you through a couple of further parameters
you can add and customize your search so it
make it a very powerful tool to actually find
interesting videos in YouTube. Each slide
I'm going to go through actually it's going
to add two parameters. One is technical, how
do you filter out or how do you manipulate
the response? And one is on the content of
the sets of videos you get. In this slide,
on the content of the sets of videos you have,
you can [INDISTINCT]. That's a very important
tool to actually select first videos that
are either most relevant to the query term
you were searching for or most recent under
the published ordering or have most view counts
or have best ratings. Those are the options
you have right now to order by. And the second
parameter I mentioned now is the technical
part of--the slide is basically filled because
the API response contains so much information
about a video. It has some thumbnails, it
has ratings, number of comments, so on, you
probably want to trim down out of the response
particularly to the part of the metadata of
the video that you were interested in. That
saves bandwidth, and that saves processing
on the client side, and you don't need to
parse this, some are already adjacent response
for anything you're not interested. And that--the
field is a great way to do it. So, for instance
here I'm just saying I want the author of
the video and the title of the video. Anything
else I don't care, so it shouldn't be returned.
So, let's say we're searching for football.
By the way, we actually get some content that
we don't want to see, we get some European
football, like, where we come from. And that's
not really football, right? So, we take it
out with -soccer on the--on the search term.
So, basically the search term accepts any
Google search operators, if you know about
those. You can read about those later into
the documentation of Google Search. But you
can say -soccer to exclude everything that
is related to soccer. And that gives us smart
accurate responses for what we want but even
that is not enough. So, we want--even though
we ordered by video count. And we want basically
those videos that have been watched a lot
lately. We don't want those videos that have
been watched a lot for the entire time they've
been uploaded for, right? So, we want something
recent. Let's say, we know something happened
in football last week. So, then we can add
time=this_week. And that restricts our search
for only videos that have been uploaded during
this week. You can also change that time into
today which gets us the freshest videos basically.
You can say this month and you can say all
the time. By default, it's all time. And on
the technical side--so, not actually changing
the content of certain responses, the paging,
so. By default, API pages are 25 entries and
they start from one. But you can do paging
as you want. So, start from 10 and have a
page that starts on 5. And that's basically
starting next and max result. And, yes, by
the way, I've added this URL on top of the
slide. So, you can actually try all this on
your phone or on your [INDISTINCT] later--or
now. They're very simple to run right now.
So, latest that--you can add safeSearch which
is basically a restriction on the content
that is--yes, we don't want videos that are
not safe for children or we don't want videos
that are not safe for certain audiences. And
that's basically safeSearch which has three
options; none, moderate, and strict. It's
again compatible with Google search which
has the same options and the same meanings
for each. And on the--and again on the technical
side we have two more parameters we're introducing
here, alt and callback. Alt basically changes
the format of the API. So, the API is very
feature rich and offers a lot of different
ways to read the metadata of the video and
parse it. We talk mostly about XML right now.
So, you're going to have an XML partner but
that may not be what you're most comfortable
with or much--what you can use in your application.
So, you can change that with the alt parameter.
And you can say atom, rss, they're both XML.
And rss, basically, it's one of the basic
usage of the API. You can use rss to follow
your friend uploads for instance, and just
have it in [INDISTINCT] and see when he uploads
a new video. Json and json-in-script, or jsonc
are basically more [INDISTINCT] script options.
That and--json parses are all over this space
and they are available in all languages. And
lastly, if you use json-in-script you can
provide a callback and my colleague, Gunther,
is going to explain how that works.
>> NOACK: So--test good, okay. So, this is--this
is a sample response that you may get when
you--when you pass these alt=json-in-script&callback=showVideos
to one of our URLs, to one of our feeds. And
so what this looks like is, this is of course
a regular json. So, it's JavaScript syntax,
you can put it into any JavaScript interpreter
and it will result in a JavaScript dictionary
which you can use to query it up basically.
And because--so without this part that says
showVideos that would be--so only this part
that would be the answer that would--that
you would get if you ask for alt=json. But
with alt=jsonc-in-script, you also get this
fancy showVideos color around it which is
of course if you'll interpret it as a JavaScript
code--as a JavaScript source file is going
be a call to a regular JavaScript function
and you can use that, that's called jsonp.
You can use that to build very simple web
apps already like this one. So, what you can
see here is--we've got, don't look at this
part currently, [INDISTINCT] whoops. What
we've got is--we've got a simple HTML page
and here we simply source with the script
tag, a JavaScript source file that is actually
located at this URL which is our--which is
one of our URLs. And because we pass alt=json-in-script&callback=showVideos,
we're going to get this response. And it's
going to call the showVideos function with
this--with this JavaScript dictionary. And
we just have to define the showVideos function
on top of that and make it--add some HTML
elements corresponding to these videos to
our HTML page. And what we're going to get
is already a very simple search application
that--oh, yes, it's in the other window. There
it is. [INDISTINCT]
>> FURNICA: So, basically this is already
a high interpretation for YouTube API and
it's just code that fits the slide.
>> NOACK: Yes. Okay. So, and then, now of
course, we have all these fancy videos and
we would like to introduce something with
them because that code does not do much yet.
And one of the things you can do with them
is that you can enable to use this to curate
that into individual playlist and organize
it and that's what Raul is going to show you.
But first before you can--before you can organize
this playlist, there's one particularly not
very nice prerequisite that you have to fulfill
and that's of course that you have to be authenticated.
And there's different authentication schemes.
So, we're going have you--have to leave you
with a bit of device about this. And it's
basically going to be this. We've got four
different authentications schemes unfortunately.
So, that's, of course, historically grown.
We have one that is called ClientLogin which
is deprecated nowadays. It is deprecated because
with this authentication scheme the user has
got to trust the application with his actual
user name and with his password. And it's
not a token based system like OAuth where
the--where YouTube itself does the authentication
or only allows the application to work with
it later. And--so, the other three authentications
scheme solved that in this way. So, the users
are going to be redirected to the YouTube
page for instance and the YouTube page will
ask him whether he wants to allow this application
to access his data on YouTube. And so AuthSub
is a Google specific solution to that which
is supported. And then there's also OAuth
1 and OAuth 2. We currently prefer OAuth 2
because it's the most recent version. The
advantage for OAuth 2 is of course that it's
OpenSource, and that it's used widely, and
there are client libraries for it. And that
may help you with implementing it. So--but
the big advice basically is choose wisely.
If you have your--if you're writing an application
and you write it in a specific environment,
specific language, just see that you can get
the most support for any of these login schemes
except ClientLogin. Yeah. Okay. And we've
got lots of material on that in our blog.
>> FURNICA: So anybody--anybody knows about
OAuth already? Oh, wow, that's more than I
expected, okay. Cool.
>> NOACK: Okay. [INDISTINCT]
>> FURNICA: So, yes, it's not a Google specific
technology, it's an OpenSource standard and
Google is implementing it as well. So that's
basically best to use in user authentication.
Anybody knows why you would use user authentication
or has a clear idea about why that's useful?
Okay. So basically it's very useful--I'm going
to go through that in the second curation
part of the talk. But it's very useful basically
if you want to get to the user account data,
right? So if you want to either retrieve information
about the user account re-login or allow the
user currently to login and give your application
access to his account data, or if you want
to change his account data. So if you want
to create a playlist for instance for the
user. Or if you want to update their favorites
or their ratings, or so on. So, in this particular
talk we're going to focus on playlist but
there is a lot of other things we can do with
authentication. So let's say you find a great
lot of video content out there for using the--in
the method mentioned in the first part of
the--of the talk and now you want to actually
help users save his content into their playlist
or keep it somewhere so that he can refind
it easily without actually searching all the
time. The first thing we need to do in order
to take one of the videos we find interesting
and put it in a playlist is basically to see
what playlist the user actually has already.
To do that we need to go through authentication
which is probably the most painful point we're
actually describing in this--in this talk.
And once you get that done, everything is
like super easy. It's like--but only that--it's
like you're probably going to spend a couple
of days figuring out what the hell is going
on here? It's our experience as well. Like
we've build a demo for this--for this presentation
in particular and we were like that as well,
"Oh my god. How do I get this going?" But,
yes, it gets better with the--with the demo
we actually have because you can see the code
and learn from our own experience. So once
we go through that and we have user authenticated
and let's say we are already sending the authorization
header which you already see there in the
request on under OAuth authorization http
header. Then we can basically retrieve a feed
under feeds/API/users/default/playlists. All
the user information--all this user's specific
information in YouTube API is basically under
feeds/API/users, under that path, and default
is basically just the way to say the currently
login users. So you don't really need to remember
the user name of the currently login user
or anything like that. You can always follow
the same URL and use the default playlist
[INDISTINCT] to refer to the current user.
So, this feed would list all the playlist
on that account. So, we here have listed playlist
on a YouTube account, YouTube basically has
its own account, we just call YouTube and
it's on YouTube so you can actually get it
if you want. You can retrieve it on YouTube.com.
And right now I'm listing the last two playlist
on that account. And the most important part
to check in this is basically that the playlist
has an ID which is highlighted there--that
is the part of the ID that is used on the
website as well, so the website and the API
actually share IDs and that is the part you
need to remember in order to be able to refer
to this playlist later. So, we can take a
list of playlists, show it to the user in
someway and then asked him to select one of
them in order to update with his video findings.
And then if we actually want to save a video
he actually likes into one of those playlists,
all we need to do is write request. A write
request is unlike the request we showed you
so far, unlike the--a simple http get, so
a simple return from a URL. They're opposed
to a URL or, in some cases, when you actually
modified the reboot, or if you delete, they
are delete to an http URL. So for instance,
if we have one thread of video with the ID
highlighter there, OaRI so on, to the playlist
with the ID D7002B and so on--I'm just talking
IDs here, that's very boring but you kind
of get the idea. You need a playlist ID to
form the URL, which playlist am I adding it
to. And you need a video ID to say which video
I might add to that playlist. The video ID
goes into the request body and that's all
you need to sign in the request body, that
you see right there, so an entry with an ID
that's it. And then if that is successful
you're going to get a response of 201 created.
And it's going to give you a full body of
the entry that has been created in that playlist.
There are--many are--there are unresponses
you can get, but hopefully you'll get this
one and that means your operation was successful.
The most unlikely to get one, trust me, it's
500 server unavailable. We're trying to avoid
that as much as possible, if that's happening
just let us know. There is a forum we're going
to tell you about it at the end. Another one
that may happen is 403 service forbidden.
What that means is either that you have not
authenticated the user currently. So, he's
not allowed to change the playlist because
he's not authenticated, or the recent authenticated
user but he's not the owner of that playlist
so he cannot make the change. That would be
quite something right? [INDISTINCT] allow
people to change other people's playlist.
That, hopefully, doesn't happen either. And
since I talked a lot about the IDs, what you're
going to see after the playlist entry has
been created is basically a composite ID of
the playlist ID and the entry ID in that playlist.
And basically it's as simple as that as creating
and managing a playlist. You can do a lot
more. You can reorder playlist. You can implement
even a better playlist experience than the
YouTube website which is not really awesome
right now, it could be made better, so. All
of that is basically available through the
API and it's really almost the same functionality
[INDISTINCT] on the website for almost everything.
But besides that let's talk about a bit of
other features available in the YouTube API,
and one of the most important ones is basically
the ability to upload of videos. And you can
do that through the upload API and basically
anything you can capture a video with and
send it over to--through the API server, it's
creating a video on a YouTube site. You don't
need to actually specify metadata so you can
just post a file and it's as simple as that,
as posting a file, and then the user is later
asked to provide more metadata for the video,
but you can also provide metadata for the
video in the same request as uploading the
video. There are a couple of community features
expose through API as well so you can like/dislike
videos, you can rate videos, you can comment
on videos, you can respond on videos with
another video. You can even share videos with
your friends or with SMS or email. And besides
that, there are a couple user-centric features
like managing favorites and subscriptions
and managing contacts on YouTube.com. And,
of course last but not the least is following
your friends' activity, so you can actually
see what are--what your friends are doing
or you can give, in your applications, updates
about subscriptions and friends on YouTube.
There's a lot more than that but I think I'm
not going to enumerate anymore because it's
going to take quite a lot. One thing to mention
though is that we have a lot of client libraries
available for the YouTube data API. And they're
all--you can check them out its goo.gl.MARLi.
I quite like--it was randomly generated, but
it's quite a nice name. There is one for Java,
C++ and Python for sure. There might be others
for JavaScript and other languages as well.
And there are also pointers to other languages
as well, over there. So it's demo time and
you can scan this link and try it.
>> NOACK: Take the mouse cursor out of the
way.
>> FURNICA: Huh?
>> NOACK: [INDISTINCT] keep the mouse cursor
[INDISTINCT]
>> FURNICA: [INDISTINCT]
>> NOACK: [INDISTINCT] anyone or everyone
done [INDISTINCT]
>> FURNICA: Okay. Yes, if scanning the bar
code doesn't work you can use the short URL
on top.
>> NOACK: Oh, yes. It's here.
>> FURNICA: We're prepared for anything. Just
to get it to demo.
>> NOACK: Okay, we're going to switch over,
so.
>> FURNICA: It's a very simple URL. It's a
YouTube--a YouTube API demo.atspat.com.
>> NOACK: Not here. Not here. Not here. Where
is it?
>> FURNICA: Here.
>> NOACK: [INDISTINCT] not to click it?
>> FURNICA: No, go back. Here.
>> NOACK: Where?
>> FURNICA: Here.
>> NOACK: Here. Here. Okay. [INDISTINCT] thanks.
Okay, so that's--so that's our [INDISTINCT]
demo app. It's showing exactly what we also
showed you in these--in these slides now.
>> FURNICA: So now we actually do what we
talked about.
>> NOACK: Right. Here you cannot, by the way,
also find this little JavaScript app that
fits on one page. So the way this app is build
as a very simple overviews, it's built in
app engine, so it's a Java served engine and
we do our API request service side. It really
depend--there is a--there are a lot of tricks
we--for instance, first we try to build something
like that client-side. We figure out it's
not actually possible because there's trust
[INDISTINCT] restrictions in where you can
do your post request to and you can't actually
modify content on YouTube from the clients
side and so this is because--so in this way
I would like--if you want to do something
that modifies content on YouTube and--where
you just have to log in, then it is a good
idea to do it server-side or at least in a
mix, so.
>> FURNICA: That is of course if you're writing
server-side app like app engine. If you're
doing an Android app or anything like that,
you just do it [INDISTINCT]
>> NOACK: Yes, right. If you're not doing
a web based app it's different of course.
>> FURNICA: Yes.
>> NOACK: Right. So, this is the various--this
is the various [INDISTINCT]
>> FURNICA: Remember first slide?
>> NOACK: First slide, exactly, about the
video charts, the different high scores, the
videos that you can see on the--on the YouTube
page itself where you can--where you can brows
videos, so yes, and what this does is basically--we've
got the source code to most of the servers
on the side as well. [INDISTINCT] see this
[INDISTINCT]
>> FURNICA: Yes, you have to--the app running
and then right next to it you have the code,
so you can take it out. I don't know how many
of you read Java. I'm going to try to add
even code for other languages. How many of
you use Java by the way?
>> NOACK: [INDISTINCT] Java...
>> FURNICA: How many of you would use Python?
And how many of you would use C or C++? Okay.
>> NOACK: Something completely different?
>> FURNICA: So, we'll use [INDISTINCT] we
need Python here. Okay.
>> NOACK: Okay, so here you can see that we
used exactly the same URL as you--as you've
seen on the first slide. Without some of these
parameters which is--in this case handled
by the client library mostly.
>> FURNICA: So basically we need two parts
to actually make a successful client library
usage. Which is basically right here in YouTube
get feed. I don't have a way to point, so
I'm doing manually but you need to have an
application name and application key. And
I didn't talk a lot about that but you can--you
can--if you need to write to the user account.
Then you need to register your application
with YouTube. There are a couple of benefits
for doing that anyway, so if you register
your application with YouTube and there is
a dashboard where you will be able to register
it under your Google account, you get--you
basically get a lot more quota for your application,
so you can--and that's of course because if
there is an abuse of your application from
someone else and we know where it's coming
from and we can alert you and let you know.
But besides that you're going to get really
nice graphs with your application traffic,
so it's going to tell you like, "Oh, your
application is being used and in particular
in these--in these features," and then that's
failing constantly and is producing errors
for the user and you can check that or that's
working wonderfully and you can see that as
well. Besides that, the application key can
be sent very easily in a header and if you
connect--if you get your applications key
from some configurations somewhere, which
is really now from a server context, and you
add it to your YouTube service which you connect
to the API server, it's basically going to
send it on every request, then you just forget
about it and do it.
>> NOACK: Okay, let's go on to the search.
Yes? Okay, so this is looking so--as a short
comparison maybe, this is the first server,
this is the second server. They look very
similar, the difference is that you can edit
the search string here basically you could--for
instance, say, search for...
>> FURNICA: Google talks. He likes the talks.
>> NOACK: Google talks, IO and you're...
>> FURNICA: I'd been seeing him searching
for Google Talks all of this week.
>> NOACK: ...you're going to--you're going
to do the...
>> FURNICA: [INDISTINCT] all last week.
>> NOACK: I watched quite a bit of them when
I hacked on this, it's true. So, yes, here
you look for instance and see some talks that
were giving at the recent IOs and...
>> FURNICA: So in this sample as well you
have a kind of well formatted title with the
kind of formatted author and the, well, unformatted
description of the video. We didn't spend
a lot of time working on this but on the formatting
part because we didn't want to showcase that.
We want to showcase API usage basically but
I'm not sure we can do a lot better.
>> NOACK: Okay, so how this works is basically
then again your--if you compare these two
servers--I'm not going to do this now in detail
but they're very similar and the only big
difference is actually that the--that, in
this case, you're going to use a different
URL and you're going to give a--give a specific
parameter and the rest--the whole--the whole
viewing part except for the little box where
you can enter the queries, is the same.
>> FURNICA: Just a bit of an addition, besides--so
before we retrieve the list--so, that's basically
something maintained by YouTube and YouTube
actually creates those list and has [INDISTINCT]
run over all the video corpus data. And they
come up with like the most viewed videos last
week and so on. In this case you're actually
running queries, so you're not connecting
to the URL directly but you're just building
the query and you have a query object that
you can use to build. And that has all the
properties that I have talked about in those
long slides about the search.
>> NOACK: Yes, yes, right. Yes. So here's
a YouTube query object that accumulates, basically,
this URL plus all the http parameters and
puts it together in a nice way, that's what
the client library does. Okay and then there's--we've
got of course, some [INDISTINCT] authentication.
I'm not going to dig too...
>> FURNICA: And now the painful part.
>> NOACK: ...deeply into this because it's
a bit more complicated and you can--you can
look it up on other web pages anyway. So,
but I'm still going to do it because otherwise
the playlist part won't work. So there's--basically
there's three steps to OAuth here in this
case. You have--first you're going to obtain
an authorize token. You're going to authorize
the token with auth. This is done by sending
the user to that YouTube page which the user
can verify as hosted at Google and he can...
>> FURNICA: He's actually [INDISTINCT] and
hopefully we're not going to see a 500 afterwards,
but...
>> NOACK: And then one second--one second.
>> FURNICA: It's the presentation effect,
if it happens.
>> NOACK: I've probably mistyped the password.
Load works, okay. So, and then...
>> FURNICA: So...
>> NOACK: ...YouTube is going to ask, "Oh,
there's this application it wants to access
your data. You want to allow it?" And then
the user's going to read that hopefully...
>> FURNICA: Sure, go ahead.
>> NOACK: ...and--oh, yes.
>> Right now, it's just all access or no access?
>> FURNICA: Right now it's just all access
or no access, yes, to the YouTube account.
>> NOACK: Yes.
>> FURNICA: But it's only to the YouTube accounts.
So, usually YouTube accounts are linked to
a Google account, you can gain access through
Gmail with the same...
>> NOACK: Okay.
>> FURNICA: And this is basically the core
of OAuth and why all the pain? Basically the
user that is being requested in the--on behalf
of your application--access for you application,
so here is--he decide if he allows or denies
your [INDISTINCT] access.
>> NOACK: Okay. So, we're going to allow it
in this case because we trust our application.
And--so then--and then you get the authorized
token and you can exchange it for an access
token that you can use for doing requests.
>> FURNICA: So we're just doing the API in--normal
Google API folks a favor here by explaining
a bit more about us. But basically OAuth has
three major steps. And in each steps, a different
kind of token is involved. In the first step
there is an unauthorized token. You just get
that and then the user has to approve your
token. That's the second step, where the user
approves this token and then that token changes
into an authorized token. And the last step,
the authorized token needs to be traded for
an access token which you can later use to
make requests on that account.
>> NOACK: And...
>> FURNICA: And right now we made actually
one authenticate request already. So we got
the user profile and we know who the user
that logged in is. So we can actually tell
him, "Hi, name."
>> NOACK: Okay. So, now that we're logged
in, we can also use the user's playlist.
>> FURNICA: Can I actually go a bit on the
code side?
>> NOACK: On what? Which codes? On the OAuth?
>> FURNICA: For the OAuth, yes.
>> NOACK: Oh, we only have a quarter of an
hour left. Shall we not?
>> FURNICA: I think we have time.
>> NOACK: As you like. Okay. So there you
go.
>> FURNICA: So this code again walks you through
all the OAuth process and it's very inline.
There is no magic happening anywhere else
and there is no method extraction. Although
we advice you probably do extract some methods
out of this because we have a very large method
to that. But basically the client library
in Java has some support for OAuth already.
And although OAuth specific classes and all
the parameters you need to specify and the
request you need to make, the client library
will help you with that. You just need to
have some configuration for reapplication.
And you actually need to register your application
with OAuth as well, for that. And in the first
step, you actually get this unauthorized token.
In the second step, you need to authorize
it by basically constructing a URL and sending
the user. So you need to give away your control
of the request of the user to Google with
the callback URL. And then Google will call
you back your application with the authorized
token when that has completed.
>> NOACK: Okay. So...
>> FURNICA: And if you open [INDISTINCT] the
My User Profile Servlet.
>> NOACK: Where is it? Oh, here.
>> FURNICA: Third, yes. And this is the first
servlet that actually makes a call with an
authorized user. So, the difference between
the ones you saw before--it still uses the
URL, it connects to that URL to retrieve the
user profile. It retrieves the user profile
of default. So that's the currently authenticated
user. And it adds the OAuth credentials, you
can see there are like, YouTube set OAuth
credential, so OAuth parameters. That's basically
what you need to send on every request, to
say I'm this--I'm authenticated as this user.
>> NOACK: All right. So, let's have a look
at the playlist very shortly and then we can
go to the Q&A. So the playlist, how that looks
as an application is--for instance like this.
So, these are the playlist that the current
user currently has. We can have a look at
them. We can edit them. Maybe rearrange the
videos in the playlist so that...
>> FURNICA: Again, don't take us as [INDISTINCT]
models.
>> NOACK: I'm not sure that helps.
>> NOACK: You probably can do a much better
than an up and down but, yes, it works, so.
>> NOACK: And so--and then there's of course--what
is--what you can also do then is that you
can have find...
>> FURNICA: So now if you remember...
>> NOACK: ...[INDISTINCT] videos. Let's see.
[INDISTINCT]
>> FURNICA: We actually did a tweak here.
If you remember when we searched the first
time, we need to have the second part where
you can actually add a video to a playlist.
Now it's there because we actually loaded
the playlist of that user.
>> NOACK: Yes. So that we--this is a bit of
hack though. So you can--you're--you can choose
the playlist that you want to add a video
too, then you can add it with this button.
And this is all then done server-side by doing
a post request to the YouTube API to a specific
URL...
>> FURNICA: So that's the last slide, basically.
>> NOACK: ...and it's going to insert a--it's
going to insert a video into a playlist and
then later the user can go to the page again
and rearrange if he likes. Yes. And we've
got the code to that as well here. It looks
very much the same as the code you've already
seen apart from that one of these codes is
called insert instead of--instead of get,
I think.
>> FURNICA: Yes. It's over there, service
insert.
>> NOACK: Here, this one. So that's--but,
that's the detail of the--of the GData Client
Library for Java. Yes. Okay. So, yes, I think
that's pretty much it. We can...
>> FURNICA: So one more thing to mention.
On the--on this page you also have a couple
of very useful links. The YouTube API homepage
basically is linked there. The reference of
the API and we have a very good documentation.
>> NOACK: Yes.
>> FURNICA: We use it to refresh our memory
about [INDISTINCT] as well. And also, we have
one of the best tech writers in Google. There
is a blog as well, where we post about new
features and there's going to be some new
features coming soon. There is a forum where
you can talk with other developers or our
developer relation engineers, our--even ourselves.
And there is a YouTube API gallery where you
can try and see what other people did with
the YouTube API. And there's some good stuff
there.
>> NOACK: So this is how our docs look like.
So it's pretty exhaustive. We've got documentation
on all of our public feeds and what you can
do, how you use them. It's often very used
cased, driven with examples. So actually for
the demo, most of the code I just copied from
the documentation. So it's not--or not quiet
but roughly. It's very--it's very--you've
got to understand a bit how this works in
XML and how this has got to do with URLs and
parameters to URLs and so on. But once you've
understood that and--then you can use the
documentation very easily to transfer that
to any client library you may use.
>> FURNICA: Okay. So, any questions?
>> NOACK: Yes. Let's go to the questions.
>> FURNICA: We're being so good at explaining
everything?
>> NOACK: Yes?
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FURNICA: Yes. The only thing you need...
>> [INDISTINCT] ready everything...
>> NOACK: Not [INDISTINCT] wide.
>> [INDISTINCT] their name, information like
[INDISTINCT]
>> NOACK: Yes. So, users can have private
information that they can only see themselves.
For instance, if you--your age on YouTube
for instance. That's a very simple example.
Or you can have private playlists and when
you're authenticated as that user you can
see that information with the regular--with
the regular--in the regular way that you would
also use for other users. And you will still
get to see this information. So that's...
>> But if you want to see the videos that
YouTube has posted and the comments that might
have been made up [INDISTINCT] videos...
>> FURNICA: That's public. Yes.
>> ...you don't need OAuth for that, right?
>> FURNICA: Yes. That's public.
>> NOACK: Yes. That mostly--of course, yes.
>> FURNICA: Yes. So, OAuth is only when you
actually want access to the user account.
Yes. Yes?
>> Is it possible to change any [INDISTINCT]
properties using the API or [INDISTINCT]
>> FURNICA: It's almost any. Yes?
>> NOACK: Yes. We've got a lot. We've--for
instance you can--basically if you go to--if
you've got an Android phone and you play with
the YouTube application on it, it's using
the API as well.
>> FURNICA: Yes. So that's the trick.
>> NOACK: So the--all this stuff, you can--you
can do yourself with the YouTube API.
>> FURNICA: We're basically implementing everything
because we also implement a lot of functionality
in our own YouTube application.
>> NOACK: Yes. So that means...
>> FURNICA: So everything that's there, it's
public as well.
>> NOACK: So that means--so most of the application
will usually do something like they're going
to--so the--the applications like on phones,
for instance, they would show some videos
that we have in the--in the video charts that
we exposed, that's the first example that
we showed you. Then they're going to allow
you to browse a bit, they're going to allow
you to upload videos. So that's also possible,
to upload videos through the API. That's a
bit more complicated though because it's so
much data. And--but you can find that all
in documentation. And so you can--you can
write videos, you can--I think you can comment
on videos, make playlist. Yes?
>> FURNICA: Anything else? Yes?
>> NOACK: Okay. Yes.
>> Can you--can you subscribe, in a way, to
a certain video for the comments?
>> FURNICA: Yes.
>> So if you can get--is it like a--like a
stream?
>> FURNICA: Yes. So every feed we talked about
it's also like an rss feed. So everything
is basically--you can subscribe to them with
an rss reader and you can see any change in
the comments of a video or like in the change
of the videos, on an account, on the playlist
or anything.
>> Is there a limit on the number of times
you can do it? Or the number of [INDISTINCT]
>> NOACK: Yes.
>> FURNICA: There is a limit and that increases
when you register your application. And then
even if--if you need--if you need more than
that, then you can just reach us in the developer
forum.
>> NOACK: Yes. So--but the limit is not that
high. Like, as a regular user, using your
cell phone, you--its very hard to hit, I think.
It's probably impossible to hit.
>> FURNICA: Yes, it's pretty generous.
>> NOACK: So you can--you can, well, have
many, many users as a--at the same time.
>> FURNICA: Oh, and by the way, it's actually
the highest traffic API at Google, so.
>> NOACK: Yes. And if--so if you're still
hitting the limits, you can--what you would
usually do is that you register and depending
then, of course if you--if you--if you want
to--if you've got something that is--that
is of value for you and for YouTube as well,
you can as well also contact us if you want
to have something very special, but tell us,
like--there's not many people doing that.
Yes.
>> FURNICA: Okay. Thank you very much for
showing up. Hope it was useful.
>> NOACK: Okay.